what the pandemic has done unfortunately
has made us very comfortable working
from home especially young people but
for a lot of us um we think that we've
won the lottery that this is the world's
greatest way to work where I can have
total freedom um uh and and make a
living and be a part of a team but for
the fact that we're not members of teams
um you know Isaac Stern said um the
famous violinist said music happens
between the notes well trust happens
between the meetings right it's the
walking into the meeting and the
chitchat and it's the walk out of the
meeting where we're continuing the
chitchat it's the bumping into somebody
in the hallway and being like Oh I meant
to tell you it's grabbing somebody and
saying hey you want to get a cup of
coffee and it's all these seemingly
innocuous little interactions that by
themselves Mount you know do nothing but
in in concert they actually build human
relationship and the problem with online
is all of those inet are gone all we
have is the meeting that's it that's all
we've got and so it's extremely
difficult to build Trust online you
actually have to do more work work it's
it's you know like any company that that
that it's just doing it the same and
just having the meetings no you have to
really do more work and artificially
create social interaction and even then
and I've had a virtual company for over
10 years even then we still have
business trips where we visit each other
and we still have offsites where we come
together as an entire team because we
know that nothing replaces nothing
replaces good oldfashioned uh human
interaction and by the way you cannot do
brainstorming or have great creativ
online it just doesn't exist um you can
do it you can do it in person very
easily because we interrupt each other
and it's you know whereas online is very
very formal like everybody's on mute
nobody wants to speak you know um uh
it's not interruptive and and and
chaotic um which is what you need for
brainstorming so so we can live in a
hybrid world we both exist but but I
think for too many they believe the
future of work is is is online and it'll
be to the detriment of the company but
worse it'll be to the detriment of the
mental health of the person who never
interacts with people I'm fully aware
and I recognize that the old working
world where everybody came to work all
the time favored the extroverts I get
that the introverts sometimes struggled
but when we went to a fully remote World
which the introverts loved now the
extroverts were struggling because they
need that human interaction right and so
there's always going to be a loser in in
in these scenarios if we choose one or
and if we truly love our teams the
correct answer is I will sacrifice some
of the time so that the people I work
can Thrive the way that they Thrive so
as an introvert I accept that I
sometimes have to come to work and as an
extrovert I accept that sometimes I have
to be uh separated because it helps my
colleagues and the point is is we're
making an active service we're making
flexible work and figuring out how work
Works uh for each other where I think
too much of the conversation has been
about me and how I like to work and
that's you're not the only person on the
team and so there is no perfect work
scenario I get that and the question is
I'm willing to sacrifice some so That
Others May thrive